Tom Curren comcast sportsnet New England
joins us on the program Tom thanks for
getting up for us how surprised were you
with last night's result start you know
on a four-day turnaround to take a team
that went to the playoffs last year and
started this season two and I'll take
him out with a third-string quarterback
and shut them out kind of embarrassing
for them and pretty alarming I think for
the rest of the week to see the Patriots
do that I would think would you see from
Jacoby percent kinda what I expected
they really I thought took care of them
with their game plan and made a lot of
stuff no single read stuff it's not
going to be complicated dropbacks that
guys there throw to him it's not get rid
of the thing but the composure of poison
we saw during the preseason was the same
thing we saw during the game the same
thing we saw last week when he got
inserted halfway through the game I mean
he does a lot of things really well and
there's so many good players veteran
players on the offense around him
including Edelman Gronkowski even though
he wasn't in there a ton solder Amendola
that I mean be throwing some pretty good
players to what was morale like when
Garoppolo went down these guys are
unbelievably composed I don't think that
it was I mean with us cover the team
it's a holy crap neither screw this will
be interesting uh with them and they're
kind of undaunted and i think that the
kid putting him into that situation to
the fact that he had have to play and
show that he had some composure and show
that he wasn't daunted by it probably
put their minds at ease pretty quickly i
think they had a scoring drive pretty
soon after he came in from not mistaken
from last sunday so don't was freaking
out um and i think that I don't know if
the Patriots like a degree of difficulty
at this point it would be kind of I hate
used the word arrogant because people
throw that around so often with the
Patriots but I don't think that they
might
the degree of difficulty I think they
like to find out just how much they can
do do you think Bella check loved the
fact that he only had a couple of days
and he had a third-string quarterback
and instead of saying hey I got all my
weapons I got brady here in Gronk and
that like this almost is back into the
laboratory for him to say all right what
can I come up with on a short turnaround
against an undefeated team it's a very
good defense in a you know what can be
an explosive offense yeah I think that's
I mean by degree of difficulty they
would rather have tom brady and rob
gronkowski out there but the fact that
they're not going to have those players
out there he gets to find out what the
character and the caliber of the team is
and he he was to keep the heat on and I
was talking to rod mayo about how
Garoppolo performed in the preseason why
it looks like crap then relative to what
he looked like in the first two games he
said just understand that in the
preseason and in training camp he puts
you in such difficult position so that
by the time the season starts you've
seen a lot of crap you've seen a lot of
things that aren't going to look the
same when you get on the field and if
you look at the preseason games he
wasn't throwing to any of the decent
players of the Patriots have offensively
a lot of them was sitting down not
playing at all so when he did get out
there he performed better so I think
that Belichick likes to find out what
the caliber of the team is and this
gives an indicator again he'd rather
have those players out there but this
kind of stuff actually galvanizes this
team when it has the positive results
Tom Curren comcast sportsnet New England
covering the Patriots joining a stand
Patrick show we talked about this
yesterday and it came to fruition of
Belichick game to game and he loves this
stuff it's rare when you're going to
single out a head coach for a game in
September but that's what I did this
morning i I just I mean that this is one
of those legacy games that and maybe
Houston's not as good as you know we
presented them to be but that's pretty
incredible performance and you shut them
out as well no I mean it's really
remarkable and I know it's a whole
coaching staff but there's nobody that
we single out like this coaching wise
like we do bella check and certainly
deservedly so after last night you know
it
I felt the same way I spent my whole
column and I said at the beginning if
you're tired of gauzy ODEs to Bill
Belichick's genius you might want to
click something else because this I'm go
on for a little bit here and that's the
funny thing about it is you immediately
say okay he's really screwed but if he
pulls this off it'll be remarkable and
not only do they not win 13 29 they win
27 to nothing against the staff you no
chalk full of coaches and ex-players
from the Patriots and I think that
actually played into when I look at it
in hindsight you know I think the
Houston Texans coaching staff was
completely unnerved by the threat of the
unknown you know I know for a fact that
the Houston coaching staff was extremely
concerned with okay who's going to play
quarterback what is he going to do was
crunk house key going to play will
Edelman be out there to the point where
they weren't really that well prepared
and they didn't play as if they were
well prepared and I think that that is
kind of the aura that Belichick brings
as well and one other point on this this
is probably the most evolved football
program that we've seen whether it be
performance-wise game to game and game
planning and intellectually how they
wharf and they do this and instead of it
being a team that kind of is celebrated
in a moment that celebrated this is the
team that has spent the last three games
without Tom Brady on a trumped-up charge
do you see where I'm going with this see
I always got to get the yeah I know and
I got it I got have you time yeah does
anybody talk to Brady I haven't spoken
to him directly no I have spoken to
people around him uh are you allowed to
is illegal or is the NFL pearly
prohibiting you from doing that well a
lot of people think I'm embedded so that
would be again a violation but I'm not
so I could if you wanted to and I'm
available at all times Tom if you listen
uh seton has a hot take now this is
probably going to be borrowed by other
shows but we're willing to give it to
you now to get a head start seat and
give Tom Curren your hot take the
Patriots give Brady and Gronk September
off moving forward so if you say you're
over smoldering right that's a scalding
hot take so if you have
say Tommy for the next three years you
know now you just added a fourth boom
just like that same thing with drunk and
you're going to be more rested and ready
for the playoffs I like it it's not
going to happen I like it but it's going
to be a little bit of a hazy a
distinctive Brady has already played get
this scene he's played two entire
season's worth of postseason football
was played 32 postseason games so it
does make sense to get a 39 year old a
little bit extra rest but you guys had
some of this is a as as national guys
with a broader view I don't think that
this does diminish Tom Brady's
quote-unquote greatness and his legacy
in seeing other players succeed I think
you name is absent it enhances Bella
checks it doesn't diminish Brady's as
much as it enhances Bella check and
people might say well that's semantics
but look Brady when you need a big game
when you big need a big moment he's
provided that Belichick is just the
constant here of he's the greatest
adjuster game adjuster that we've ever
seen maybe in all the sports he's that
good from game to game quarter to
quarter half to half and so I just think
it enhances his greatness you've already
heard that conversation all this this
does nothing oh absolutely but those are
people just don't like Brady that I'll
say anybody can win with that that group
and anybody could have won those Super
Bowls and it's funny too because we're
only what 18 19 months removed from him
coming back against the seattle seahawks
with 14 points in the last ten minutes
and people say well Jacoby Brissett
could do that let me think about it I'm
etrade Brady seriously that's the point
we're at that's the point where active
there will keep your head up though oh
by the way have you do you think now
Jimmy grumpel they drop these
quarterbacks hoping they can put them in
the system and get a first-round draft
pick for them what happens to grappa low
in a year year and a half that's going
to be what's really interesting because
this Belichick alter form in that case
and you know stick with someone I mean
he said a thousand times or at least a
few it's better to move on early then
move on late and would he be able to
withstand divorce from Tom Brady who has
his sign through 2019 but with two
extremely manageable salaried seasons of
40 million dollars in 2018 and 2019 but
as Garoppolo going to want to stay to be
a backup for a couple more years or
would Belichick be willing to pull the
trigger on getting rid of he gets guys
gets rid of guys a year early than a
year late normally yeah that's what I'm
saying I mean if in 2017 I think that
they'll put a for sale sign out on Jimmy
Garoppolo this offseason and if somebody
makes a ridiculous offer terrific if not
at the end of 2017 the Patriots are
going to have to make a decision do they
want to go through the drama of a Brady
trade to which a million teams would
probably lineup was not that many but 31
teams might lineup or 25 and say yeah
we'll do that where do they allow
Garoppolo to go free and clear with no
compensation from them because I can't
see them resigning him through 2020 or
2021 so we can just stand around and
we're headphones and look handsome it's
going to be interesting note that
because it feels like they may have
finally found a disciple of brady and
and so what do you do when when his
contract comes up but we got plenty of
time to get to that so doubt yeah all
right Tom thanks for joining us as
always and we we appreciate it I want
you to have a good weekend Tom I I want
you to have a great weekend on it ok tom
e Curran or Tommy current comcast
sportsnet New England the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you